thanks for coming everybody it's good to
see a nice full room
so
um
sequels been around a long time and
when it started off it was just you know
database language
and then
um
I got involved in SQL first time around
1995.
and since then sql's grown a lot and
people have added extensions to SQL for
all kinds of things so
um they had a geospatial awareness to
SQL
they added document storage you could
have like nested tables they added XML
Json data types all kinds of things to
SQL but it's really curious that the one
thing that has been around and on top of
SQL for a really long time
is Analytics
the first bi tools were coming out
around like 1995 things like business
objects and and so forth
and they are still separate
beings they are still they're still
separate software components and
they don't speak so they generate SQL
but you don't talk to them in SQL
um they look a lot like databases they
have catalogs full of objects that you
define
they have some of them have user
interfaces some of them don't I mean you
know analysts are talking about headless
by bi these days so these things kind of
are like databases and so I just started
thinking
what is exactly is that they do and how
different are they are they from SQL
databases
so um
yeah so here are some possible reasons
that bi tools are separate from SQL and
on top of SQL
um one is they provide a semantic model
although
what exactly is a semantic model this is
a kind of topic for debate
um they obviously kind of Drive
visualization they can kind of you can
say that you know this field is supposed
to be green and they're supposed to have
this format string they provide
governance layer so you know who's
running which queries that kind of thing
um they allow you to kind of more
concisely kind of pre-join tables and
and you know reduce some of the kind of
common effort of defining these queries
um and they allow you to Define
calculations otherwise known as metrics
or measures I tend to call them measures
um and they allow you to kind of ask
complex questions and they allow people
that don't know how to write SQL to ask
those questions so that's what they do
but I'm going to focus especially on the
last on the last two
um
and I just said well why can't we do
some of those things especially those
last two things why can we not do it in
SQL if we could do it in SQL then
we could do all these good things we
could like move the processing to the
data right as opposed to pulling the the
data into the the the bi tool we could
just leave it in the SQL database
because Cloud SQL databases have just
immense scale and a very convenient
convenience and so forth
we've removed the data lag because when
you if you're copying data from your SQL
database into your bi tool then the data
might be an hour or a day behind reality
and your users are just saying well
why does this number not match this
number right
and by the way if you've got multiple bi
tools
um the models are going to be different
in those bi tools so now you've got a
maintenance effort or if now you've got
a maintenance effort because you've got
to maintain the same definitions of
profit or whatever it is in the two
different places
and sql's on open language which kind of
means it basically tends to win in the
end
um I mentioned all those other kinds of
workloads and domains
um uh you know before they before people
started doing geospatial processing in
SQL people said no you don't understand
geospatial it can't be done in SQL and
yeah you know now it's happening in SQL
why is it hard well
um it is a different Paradigm it is a
higher level language in some sense the
data model is more complex because
there's you know these Concepts like
hierarchies and so forth
and we can't do any changes that are
going to break SQL
um we don't we can't change the
semantics of SQL in such a way that
people exist to people's existing
queries give different answers
so what's this talk actually about
because I
um you know I work for Google I founded
Apache Cal site I work for Looker
um
and I've actually do some work on SQL
standards so what exactly am I trying to
change here well
initially I'm this is kind of a an
experiment like I'm just kind of
scratching the itch and just saying look
how could the world be better
um in the short term I'm doing these
changes in in Apache calcite
um so that you know we can play with
them
um
if these if these experiments are
successful I think it potentially makes
SQL engines much more powerful you know
you can solve problems they can't
already solve and so I would expect and
actually hope to see other SQL engines
um you know things Google produces but
also produced by Google's competitors
adopting these syntax extensions and if
that happens that would be great
um another reason I'm doing this talk is
I I really don't hear very good formal
definitions of the sum of the semantic
model the metrics layer I don't I
haven't really seen good definitions of
what a metric even is
um and this
this this this I found this disturbing
um and
um I'm on a mission to make SQL and API
for data so think of it as not just this
in the same way that uh you know HTTP or
HTML is a API that you know you can or
SMTP is a way that you know uh it's not
just the thing you use just to to send
you an email it's the it's the protocol
that all the different mail transfer
agents on the internet use to talk to
each other so I think if SQL as a
language by which all these different
Data Systems talk to each other and if
they can be talking a higher level
language that understands analytics
Concepts this is you know this has got
to be good
let me use a metaphor here
um
and so just just just bear with me okay
um we want to make Italian food for
dinner right
and a one way of you doing it is using a
pasta machine
um where this metaphor is going is that
um the way SQL and relational algebra
does stuff is like the pasta machine and
I'm going to claim that what we want is
something more like pizza delivery so
here goes so
if you want to make let's suppose you
want to make green spaghetti right you
start off with the dough and you uh you
mix in spinach paste so it's green and
you feed it through a machine like this
and cuts it into like strips or whether
it extrudes it or whatever
um if you change your mind or you know
your wife gets home and she says she
wants light red tortellini tonight then
you have to make a new a new batch of uh
of dough right you like mix in some
sun-dried tomatoes and then you roll it
out into a sheet and then you cut it up
into squares or whatever
so and you notice there you had to make
a new a new batch of dough and you had
to go through all of the steps of the of
the recipe to like you know make this
new kind of pasta
whereas if you uh initially you're going
to order a pizza like this with olives
and Anchovies and your wife comes home
and says she wants like pineapple or
whatever
you just you just call it you just call
the shop and you just say can you change
that pizza to a pineapple ham and
pineapple pizza
so you don't have to go through all the
steps again you just change your order
right so
obviously this one's a lot quicker right
it's a it's a lot more concise it's it's
a it's a two sentences rather than a
recipe which is three pages long
and so I'm going to claim that
relational algebra which is the way SQL
is built
um you tend to go you tend to specify
these recipes
you know you start off with these tables
and you join them together and you join
in another table and then you aggregate
it and uh if you happen to need the same
data for a different year then you
basically do the same thing except you
throw away a bunch of a different set of
data and then you self join the data
together
um and on the other hand the
multi-dimensional model it's not about
storing data in cubes okay the data is
stored is still stored in a relational
database right we all know this but you
just write your queries you just say I
want this value I want to know the
um uh how much revenue I got from this
supplier
um in January 2022
and if you want a you know a similar
value the year later you just change the
coordinates so by specifying the
coordinates you know you've changed the
anchovies to olives or whatever it is uh
you've just got this other calculation
now in order to calculate that cell that
the the system underneath might have had
to just reload you know read another
terabyte of data or perhaps reread the
same terabyte of data you don't know and
you don't care you shouldn't have to
tell it the recipe every time it needs
to calculate this thing right
so
I'm talking about multi-dimensional
queries so these are the kind of queries
that are easy or perhaps possible to
express
in the second model and they're possible
to express in SQL but they're just pages
of code
um by the way um I see Lloyd's here
Lloyd and I work for the same company
there's a lot of parallels between our
talks because we're all thinking about
the same problems and I I'm hugely
inspired by the lawyer that do the work
that Lloyd did at looker before I even
got there so we are
um the the huge amounts of code that
sequel that Lloyd was gleefully showing
on the screen are again the same kinds
of you know huge amounts of SQL that I'm
trying to kill
um
you know we we none of us want to write
this stuff so these are the kinds of
queries that you would have to generate
write large amounts of SQL to get them
um I end up with a slightly different
place than Lloyd which is you know I
wanna I wanna I wanna fix SQL rather
than build a new language but uh compare
and contrast
um so yeah for each product
um for each product category find the
top five suppliers last year based on
total sales that's that's one kind of
thing another another kind of query
um
um so for each for each product category
find the highest sales in that category
which product was the highest sales in
that category last month
find that set of of products and tell me
what the sales of them were this month
right
so this this there's this kind of
dimensional shift going on last month
versus this month right
and then another one
um for a particular supplier called Ace
um uh
and each product give me the fractional
increase in sales from uh last January
to this January
so um this is uh
uh how you'd write it in SQL and on the
right just for references MDX which is
the language that my Mondrian server
implemented it was the language
introduced as part of Microsoft analysis
services and I would say this is kind of
the textbook example of a dimensional
query language
um and the mdx's you know
the the the the the identify names are
quite long in MDX and so it's it's
fairly bulky but you'll see it's a lot
less concise than the sequel and if you
kind of delve into the SQL you'll see
this basically two very similar looking
queries
um joined to each other because we have
to read the data from 2022 to find out
you know the the uh
what was the revenue in 2022 and we also
have to read the data for 2023 and then
we have to join them together
now you could do this using windowed
aggregate functions if you're clever but
it requires a lot of cleverness
um
uh you the you notice it's a left join
here so you have to kind of do some you
know clever thinking making sure you're
not doing some double counting
um so not only is this a long piece of
SQL But It's tricky to write and tricky
to maintain and somebody somewhere is
just going to break something
which means your reports start giving
the wrong answers
um so I'm proposing changes to SQL where
you can do this using measures and
the measure in this case
is called some sales I've defined it
once
and rather than reading the data twice
we're reading it once or specifying the
query once
we're we're interested in 2023 January
um but
um we're also able to evaluate 2022.
so I hope you can see this is you know
vastly superior to the one on the left
and it's the it's the don't repeat
yourself principle is is in operation
here
um because if you have to repeat
yourself once you probably have to
repeat yourselves 10 times and these
queries can just grow out of control
so I mentioned self joins windowed
Aggregates there's a lot of kind of
connections behind the scenes to these
things um Windows aggregate functions I
think were devised as a way of avoiding
certain kinds of soft joins and they
work for certain things but they don't
work for this scenario where you've
thrown away the data for 2022 but you
still want to read it so windowed
aggregate functions only work on the
stuff that's coming out of your from
Clause
um
so measures are in the sense the
generalization of windowed aggregate
functions
and by the way databases one good one
good reason to use windowed aggregate
functions is
that if if you specify your query as a
windowed aggregate rather than a
self-join the database can often
evaluate this as a one pass if it's for
example calculating the
um
uh the salary of each employee and the
fraction of that of that's the the ratio
of that employee's salary to the uh
entire the department the entirely
salary budget of that department it can
do that in one pass over the data
um so there's a lot of good reasons to
use windowed aggregate functions and
measures give give this kind of same
kind of locality of computation
um that databases even though they can
do joins they don't like doing them then
you'll you so this is not only more
concise but
um more efficient
so what's a measure
um
just can anyone Define a measure for me
or a metric
no
all right so most people would agree
that this thing here some of sales or
otherwise known as Revenue that's a
pretty obvious candidate for a measure
right
um it's a column with an aggregate
function
um
but what about this a ratio is that a
measure it's not a simple aggregate
function
um you can't if you're going to define a
summary table you can't easily store
this in the summary table because ratios
don't roll up right you have to you have
to store sales and cost as separate
columns and you have to do the
calculation last right so is this a
measure I I think so yeah
um
what about this so
I claim this is the the definition of
measure that we want to use it's a
column that when you use it as an
expression in any context like given a
year or given a product or whatever you
can evaluate it it might have an
aggregate function in but it might call
some like web service like what's the
exchange rate of that in that region of
that currency on that date right well
what was the temperature on that day the
temperature might be stored in some
table somewhere you don't know right you
shouldn't have then your users don't
have to know they just it's just a
function from all the dimensions to a
value on the screen and it's very
similar to what statisticians call a
dependent variable
so that's what I think a measure should
be
his forecast is interesting so let's
suppose you've got some forecast
function right that uh will tell you
what the revenue is going to be in 2025
based on you know the past 10 years of
data and you know looking at like
seasonally adjusted averages and
whatever so it's imagine it's not is it
summing up data not really
um because there isn't any data yet but
it still produces a value at a moment in
time and I would claim that's a measure
um so
um a lot of bi tools have a very narrow
definition of a measure and I I want to
just broaden it out
so
um what are we working with here so SQL
has a table model and SQL in SQL tables
are really important because you've got
like what we generally call tables base
tables but views are
kind of derived tables right they're
tables that are defined by a query but
when you look at a view you can it's
impossible to tell whether
um
uh you're looking at a view or a table
maybe the performance is different but
in terms of the data that comes out if
you have a query that runs on a view
and you replace it with a table with the
same rows in it it produces the same
results in all circumstances right and
that that's a kind of a one of the basic
contracts of SQL you can replace a view
with a table or a sub query or a CTE and
it produces the same results
and that's that's the key part of the
architecture that makes SQL hold
together
so here I write a table sorry I write a
query
and I can use it as a sub query right
um
and
I can use that subquery as a sub query
so
um
and then I can replace that query by a
table and I can replace that query by a
table
except look at what I'm doing here
I'm calculating
average salary right
and it returns a number
and then I'm confusing the average of
the average salary to get another number
that's probably not what I want what I
want to do is calculate the average
salary but the rules of SQL is this
query has to return
the same as if I substitute it in this
table
so I'm not allowed to return a you know
a summon account behind the scenes I
have to return a value
and I thought I'm just not allowed to
change the semantics of SQL so I get
what I want which is a average salary
that can be evaluated you know when it
finally get to the top level right so
SQL is broken or SQL is actively
stopping me doing the thing I want to do
here
um
so I'm proposing to change SQL so that
tables can have measures
so
and queries can return measures right so
here similar looking query except
average salary as measure
and I'm telling you don't return a value
return an expression okay
and so I can use this inside another
query right and this thing is taking
this average salary and returning
another expression
so this is an expression it's still an
expression up here and then finally on
the on the actor query I'm actually
using that expression for real and
turning it into a value so this gives me
the answer that I want to
and by the way if I decide I'm going to
join
departments in
um
then uh
that measure is not going to be polluted
by the extra rows it's still locked into
the the same evaluation context
so
again these are analytic tables they are
basically views on one of their columns
is a measure if you don't use that
measure column then it just behaves like
a regular table so you just get regular
SQL semantics
so this is the core of the extension
um why is this important
I believe a data system is kind of
really has three components and they all
have to be strong and
um by increasing the power of the query
language
we can then write these queries and we
can Define views or analytic views I
guess I'd call them
and we can build a strong data model
that's based on these queries and
um
and then obviously we need an engine to
process them but I think what was
missing in a lot of uh what was missing
in SQL was this query language that was
not powerful enough to create a data
model that was powerful enough to do bi
so uh briefly overview of the syntax how
are we doing for time by the way
okay good
great so
um yeah I've just a preview of the
syntax so we're that we're introducing
one is this as measured a clause which
is this way of defining a measure in a
query as an expression
um we've got a new aggregate function
called aggregate that uh
really does nothing but just makes when
you use a measure in in a in a group by
query it makes it look like you're you
call it you're using an aggregate
function so it just makes tools and
users more comfortable with using
measures
the ass operator is
um I guess it's the
this is kind of the single most powerful
thing which is the ability to do these
cross-dimensional calculations so take
this measure or this context sensitive
expression and evaluate it in a
different a slightly different context
so evaluate it you know you might be
looking at 2020 but let's evaluate this
thing in 2019 you might be looking at
this in California but let's look at it
for the whole country
um
so and this this at expression can have
context modifiers like clear Dimension
which is what how you do you know
evaluate for the whole country
you can say set set the dimension so set
the year equals year minus one or set
year equals 2020. visible and all I'll
get to those later but they relate to
how the measures evaluated when there's
a where Clause present
um and then lastly the per function is a
way of doing multi-level aggregation
I'll get to that later as well
so
um
plan of attack right first of all
um uh add measures to the model
um second have a way to define measures
in queries and then third Define uh
context sensitive expression so you can
do cross-dimensional calculations
um
so let's look at briefly look at how the
semantics work are so you just get a
this is kind of a sketch of how the
engine would implement this stuff or at
least how you figure out what would be
the right total the right result so
let's look at this example query right
analytic employees and I've got a single
measure defined as average salary
so you just imagine that there's a
there's a type which is the the kind of
the row which is the all of the
dimension columns
um in this row
and you can kind of Imagine when you
define a measure that the system goes
behind the scenes and basically defines
a function
um
and uh
this function is a function that if you
call it you're not going to call it but
the systems the system is going to call
it later on you have to pass in a
predicate which says which set of rows
you're interested in
so
um and this this thing is
um
and we pass in what I'm calling a row
predicate which is a
um
also a function that returns a Boolean
value that says do I want this or I
don't I right and you might for example
pass in a predicate that returns yes if
the year is 2020 and know if the year is
not 2020 right so this is how we're
going to evaluate this measure
um in a particular context
and by the way a measure is something
you should be able to evaluate it in any
context you like right
um
so let's look at a query that's using
this measure so we're using average
salary we're actually using it twice
right we're using it let's suppose we
are in
um currently evaluating the row for
department number equals 10 right when
we evaluate the first one we're looking
at the evaluate the average salary
measure for Department 10. the second
one we're looking at average salary with
no department number in other words the
grand total of all rows
um
so the system when it sees you using
average salary will substitute in this
call to this function
and oh geez well
imagine there's a little right arrow
here I think this is a like a
Google Slides isn't isn't rendering
properly so we're passing in two
different lambdas right a Lambda that
that says uh get compute the average
salary for all rows in the current
department and this is this is saying
compute the average salary for all rows
period
um and this is the the kind of rewrites
that we're doing inside calcite you
don't have to write this
um
and then lastly the planner sees this
and makes it more efficient and in fact
it's able to convert this into a pretty
straightforward query we're using
actually a windowed aggregate function
here
so um
the per operator that I mentioned
earlier so another thing that people
want to do is evaluate measures at the
right grain so
um one thing you could do is
um
an individual order but there's no Group
by Clause right you're looking at an
individual order can you what's the
revenue of an individual order is that
well defined yes it is you can evaluate
a measure at the level of a single row
right
um
some is additive so what's the easiest
way of compute Computing all of the the
revenue for all orders in the country
ever well you just you know you just can
translate it to a SQL aggregate function
but there's some measures that are
non-additive where you basically have to
decompose it into aggregate functions
and then compute the ratio as the last
thing you do in the query
but there are other other measures that
are like semi-additive where you need to
if you want to compute the inventory of
all products in all warehouses in
California
uh you basically need to look at the
inventory on the last day of the quarter
or whatever it is and then sum up those
inventories you don't sum up the daily
amounts because then you'd end up over
counting so that's an example of a kind
of classic example of the semi-additive
measure that has a different roll-up
rule for when you're rolling up over the
time Dimension than for other dimensions
and then a weighted average is if you're
interested in what's the um
let me see the daily average revenue
so you're you're interested in taking
the 90 days and the quarter treating
those uh those 90 values equally in
Computing average that's not the same as
saying what's the average revenue per
order
so you need this per order date
basically allows us to compute
intermediate totals
um some revenue and and then compute the
average over the over those 90 equally
weighted values so this per operator
allows us to do this um uh weighted uh
to reduce the to do an intermediate
aggregation to a particular grain and
then aggregate later
um I said I'd get back to visible so
um here's an example of a query we're
saying job is not equal analyst
so
we've used a measure called Samsung and
then we've written an aggregate function
some parentheses Sol
and what's interesting is that
there's some discrepancies here right
for Department 20 the measure returns a
different thing and the grand total is
different what is the what's the
difference anyone want to guess no
no
exactly analysts are getting counted so
there are some analysts in Department
20. I filtered them out right
there's no row here for analysts but we
asked the measure we said give us the uh
this this expression
we're asking for what is the salary some
of the salary at Department 20 we didn't
say what's the sum of the salary of all
of the rows I printed in in Department
20 right
some in some context yeah that's the
number you want right in other contexts
that's the number you want right
so and likewise this number here there
might be some departments where all of
the employees are analysts and so they
won't even have appeared in this but we
still want them to contribute to this
total
so which one do we want visible or
non-visible well
we
obviously either makes sense right
in in SQL aggregate functions you have
no choice right it always gives you the
total of the visible rows but um uh
using this syntax at visible or at all
you can control whether you're getting
the visible total is all the non-visible
totals
measures don't require group buys this
is going back to this thing that
measures are not necessarily aggregate
functions right the average salary
measure is perfectly well defined when
I'm looking at just one employee right
or if I'm looking at a window at
aggregation there's no group buying this
query if I'm interested in
all employees who are hired into the
same job in the year preceding you know
what's the average salary of that cohort
of employees that again is well defined
right so measures can be used in these
contexts as well
um
so this kind of leads me to this like
perusal of what
what
um
what are semantic models and are they
databases or are they are they something
else so
here are some questions asked you know
why
um shouldn't this semantic model be
outside the database all my bi tools
have their own semantic models right
then and they they tell me what they do
can't be done in SQL
um and I don't want to be locked into my
SQL vendor I love my bi tools right
all 17 of them
um
I've got a great semantic model why do I
need a query language my users don't
want to write SQL
and what even is a semantic model so
here this is a matter of opinion
um
I think a semantic model is the place
where you want to share data and
calculations
you wanted to you want calculations
important calculations like a definition
of Revenue and a definition of profit
you want those to be defined Central in
one place so that everyone that's using
it is using that and that's a problem if
you've got multiple bi tools or if you
do some of your operations in SQL and
some of your operations through Tableau
and some of your operations through
looker that's a problem right getting
those calculations synchronized
um
a semantic model needs a really good
query language because you know when
you've defined these metrics what
exactly does it mean to use a metric
well you have to use it in a I believe
you need to use it in a dimensional
context you need to be able to say
evaluate profit for all the products
that I sold two years ago but didn't
sell one year ago right that's part of
the query language how you use this
thing
um and what's a really good query
language
SQL right
um so um this doesn't mean your semantic
model becomes a database just because it
speaks SQL a SQL I think of as an API
that all these data components can talk
to each other so this thing that speaks
SQL
is has it become a database well that's
kind of a matter of Pardon upon
semantics
I just think SQL should be the language
that you're speaking to this semantic
model
and all the other things they still need
to be done Access Control governance
guiding guided navigation for users who
don't speak SQL you know drag and drop
all that building dashboards all that
stuff still has to be done
and and
um
so in summary
this top-down evaluation model in other
words the pizza model of specifying
things is it's an old idea right the
multi-dimensional model came about at
least 30 years ago probably 50 years ago
but it's a really good idea it makes
queries more concise which means you
don't have to repeat yourself
it means that you can express a query in
approximately the same amount of text as
if you're talking to your CEO and the
elevator and the CEO says can you can
you you know make me a report on XYZ and
so this brings us up to a high level
language which is kind of similar to the
amount of information in an English
question
um measures make calculations reusable
so that we can use
um reuse the ReUse capabilities in SQL
like views as a way of defining
something once and then using it in many
queries and measure because because we
can use measures in queries and because
SQL can store queries in it to build a
model in other words views then we can
start building a a very rich model that
composes really well and lastly this is
the you know this is like the biggest
factor is we don't want to break SQL or
we want to we want to break SQL in a
controlled way so if people don't want
to use measures they don't have to
so
there's some references here if you want
to drill into some of the details of
like the bugs I've been working on and
some of the you know some of the
readings
um
I'm going to post these slides on my
Twitter account Julian Hyde the
recording will be posted I'm not sure
when but uh follow me on Twitter if
you'd like these slides and with that
any questions
foreign
[Music]